I'll continue from where I was,
and I'll add this to it. So,
yeah, where I was is essentially like,
how would you use two timeframes now? How would you use multiple timeframes?
Okay, we've shifted bearish. We did monochrome.
I'll come down to the one-minute timeframe. And when you're on the one-minute timeframe,
what we need to see is, we need to see a change of character
to the downside. That realigns the one-minute then with the 15-minute.
That's two timeframes aligned. When we see that,
so Internal,
High, Chalk. That's a change of character to the downside.
Now the one-minute is aligned with the 15-minute.
You look to take an entry from where you are right now, and you're
in your position. It's that simple.
What I'm going to do, though, is, of course,
those things come into a later date, and a lot of the master key,
if you've seen that, is us taking you up our setups and how to,
you know, use our strategy with this indicator.
So you're got the indicator here, but you've got the master key part,
and that gives you our strategy. So,
you know, if you want to go through that, you'll be able to see
our actual strategy and how we use it then to take positions like this.
But yeah, that's kind of, that's kind of the first,
the first thing episode, really. It's pretty simple.
It's how to read swing structure with the indicator.
The indicator does it for you. You know, you're,
wait, I'm down here. Feels weird. Feels like,
yeah. Yeah, so, how to read swing structure with
the indicator. Pretty simple.
You know, it's done for you. You don't really need to know how to
read it. You need to just know how to follow it, which is kind
of what I've showed you how to do here. You just know how to
follow this now and learn how to use more timeframes and things like
that. Directional bias chart that's in the top,
which there's going to be another recorder now. But yeah,
if there's any questions about that, you know,
tag me in the community, tag Lewis,
you know, drop a message, let us know if you've got any questions,
but pretty simple. It's pretty straightforward.
You know, the indicator does it all for you, you just need to know
how to follow it with an indicator, and use your,
your entry models, your strategies to, to take your positions.
But now you have a mechanical way of always reading the structure,
so it's always going to be the same. You know, there's no randomly guessing,
or, hoping you got the highs right, hoping that you're trading the right trend,
you, you have that already done. Your job now is just to get in
and out. But yeah,
any questions?
What was that, bro?